ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Academy governor and chair of the makeup
and hair stylist branch Leonard
engelmann this is the 30 year
anniversary of the annual academy award
for makeup the film clip you just saw
was from 1981 and last year Rick Baker
received another Oscar ironically this
time for the werewolf also shot in
London since 1981 rick has received 12
Oscar nominations which brought seven
Oscars for him great accomplishment
it is my honor to be your host on behalf
of the academy of motion picture arts
and sciences and also on behalf of the
makeup artist and hairstylist branch to
welcome you to the 84th Annual Academy
Award oscar-nominated makeup artist and
hairstylist symposium it's a long name
this year for the first year the
symposium is going to be streamed live
so we welcome viewers and hopefully many
viewers around the world the nominated
films this year are a wonderful example
of the very vast range that is the art
of makeup and the vast range of the
selection process within the makeup
artist and hairstylist branch our first
film Albert Nobbs is recognized for the
transformation of the actresses Glenn
Close and Janet McTeer for both makeup
and hairstyling
our second film harry potter and the
deathly hallows part 2 is recognized for
makeup and hairstyling for the entire
film and our third film The Iron Lady is
recognized for makeup and hairstyling
for the Margaret Thatcher character
played by meryl streep so we have Albert
Nobbs harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 2 and the iron lady before
we go too far I would like to recognize
a few people in the audience and I would
like to ask you to stand when I call
your names these are individuals who
have been nominated for oscars and
received Oscars if we could bring the
lights up a little bit for that we have
bill Corso Kevin Haney
Lance Anderson Matthew bungle michael
west north john jackson
rick baker IDI French deborah lamiya den
over Lynn barber scott wheeler Beatrice
de Alba Zoltan ela Robert short
also I'd like to recognize some of the
cast from the makeup television series
face-off will you please stand all those
front that are on the cast of face off
okay where we are
be sure and watch face off wednesday
night at ten o'clock you'll see amazing
artistry and a lot of drama I'd like to
thank the Academy's Randy Hebert camp
and his team for all the work the
coordination and making this function
take place it's a wonderful time for
these eight nominees to bask in their
accomplishments and recognition some of
you in the audience may have contributed
to these films and should be sharing in
that glory so audience enjoy this time
applaud make noise celebrate with these
nominees because that's what this all is
all about let's start right now
today is a celebration of winners every
nominee that steps on the stage this
stage is a winner and every nominee that
steps off the stage today as a winner
every nominee tomorrow is a winner one
group will carry a statue at the end of
the night but every nominee is a winner
I was very impressed a few years ago
with comments that now past Academy
President Sid Ganis made at an Oscar
nominees luncheon and I would like to
again share some of those thoughts with
you he said the reason the Academy gives
Academy Awards is to honor and celebrate
the art of the motion picture it's why
the Academy exists the red carpet and
the press attention and the parties and
the dresses are all wonderful fun
accessories to the event but the Oscar
exists to shine the brightest possible
light on you and your work the Oscar
exists because the founders believed
that movies were not just a business and
that people needed to be reminded of
that the Oscar exists to tell the world
that filmmaking is an art and it's being
practiced by some people at a very very
high level and some of those people are
in the room today before we hear from
our Oscar nominees I would like to
explain the process that brought us to
today in both April and October the
makeup artist and hairstylist executive
committee meets and at this point we're
discussing certain business but they
also discuss the films that have been
released up through that period of time
these films are the committee that the
committee feels that all of the
membership should see so that as time
goes on they can continue those films or
if need be eliminate them a meeting is
then held in December for all of the
Academy makeup artists and hairstylists
branch members
to narrow down or add to the recommended
films to be seen january then becomes a
finalization month a really busy month
for all of the branch the first saturday
of january all members were asked to
attend a meeting to vote for the seven
films that will go on for consideration
not for nomination these are selected as
the seven best films for achievement in
makeup and hairstyling for the year I'd
like to point out how unbiased these
selections are as I read the seven films
that forty members in attendance chose
first we have Albert Nobbs filmed in
Ireland we have anonymous filmed in
Germany and England we have the artists
actually filmed in Hollywood filmed in
Hollywood by a French production company
with French actors then we have
gainsbourg a heroic life filmed in
France we have harry potter and the
deathly hallows part 2 filmed in england
and we have the iron lady filmed in
england as you can see seven great
accomplishments in the artistry of
makeup and hairstyling I would like to
point out from a non-biased standpoint
that of 15 possible nominees nine were
not Academy members and 12 were not
iatse local 706 members of the eight
final films three-on-three our Academy
are of the nominees three our Academy
members one lives in Los Angeles one in
New York and one in England the second
Saturday of January the makeup artists
and hairstylists executive committee
meets and this is probably the most
difficult of the meetings because at
this time they have to select the two
films maximum of two films possibility
of a third that will be the individuals
nom
with their films and in this case they
are looking at the person or persons who
are most responsible for each film or
character or characters within each film
that is being recognized so it doesn't
matter what the ads may say it doesn't
matter how much was spent on advertising
it doesn't matter what someone has in
their deal memo and it doesn't matter
the film credits at this point the
executive committee has to make the
decision based on input and the work
that was done in 1986 prior to there
being a yearly Oscar for makeup Planet
of the Apes was going to receive a
special Academy Award there was to be
one statute that award was as the
process of the time would have gone to
the makeup department head of 20th
Century Fox dance tree peck dan said the
person most responsible for this
achievement is john chambers and he must
receive the Oscar it is that standard of
honesty and responsibility that we
follow today as the committee
painstakingly chooses the individuals
most responsible for what was being
recognized in that film then on the
third Saturday all the makeup artists
and hairstylists members are involved in
the selection screening meeting often
referred to as the bake-off this is when
the final nominations were chosen for
the academy award for best makeup for
2011 as you can see the makeup artist
and hairstylist Academy members spend a
tremendous amount of unselfish time in
an effort to applaud the work of others
today you're going to actually see how
that process takes place I'm going to
ask each of the nominees to talk about
some of the work that that that took
place and what it is that you'll see in
the clips that they're going to present
will then show the 10 minute clips of
chosen segments from their films so you
can see that wonderful where
and then after the third clip has been
seen we will open the floor for your
questions of the nominees followed by a
great reception downstairs in the lobby
the motion picture industry is a global
industry today and as once again you
will see as we introduce the nominees
please welcome for Albert Nobbs Matthew
mungol Matthew please come up and take a
seat Matthew is credited as the special
makeup designer this is the fourth Oscar
nomination for Matthew he was nominated
for a ghost of Mississippi Schindler's
List and Dracula where he won an Oscar
his other awards his other awards
include BAFTA nominations for Dracula
and Schindler's List now as an aside
Matthew also has 19 Emmy nominations
which include five wins he's joining us
from Los Angeles where he and his lab or
preparing for CSI NCSI house and a
photoshoot with an Lebovitz and we have
Lynn Johnson latest credit as to the
prosthetic application and key makeup
artists this is the first oscar
nomination for Lynn Lynn is joining us
from Dublin Ireland where she just
completed filming Byzantium
and we have marcial carnival Marcy L is
credited as wig maker and hair stylist
this is the first Oscar nomination form
RCL his other or awards include a BAFTA
nomination for a hundred and one
dalmatians marcial joins us today from
New York marcial the master wig maker is
presently making wigs for james spader
for lincoln Carey Mulligan for inside
Llewyn Davis and Linda Edmonds for death
of a salesman Albert Nobbs was filmed in
Ireland and two weeks ago won the Irish
Film and Television Awards for Best
makeup and hairstyling can you hear me
okay and we have a special guest with us
today miss Glenn Close
so great to have you here Glenn Glenn I
know this was a project of yours for
quite some time you were producer on it
and I know that you and and Matthew and
Marcy L had been working things out it's
a brave move to go from the beautiful
lady that we normally see to Albert
Nobbs a nice looking nice looking man
but not what we would normally expect to
see and you tell us a little bit about
that that working relationship you had
with Matthew and and Marcy L well I
wouldn't be here today without them I'll
just say that right now and our
collaboration really started it was
about three years ago when it looked
like we're actually going to make the
movie and at least we had gone farther
far enough along the path that it seemed
possible and I had to convince myself
that somehow we could create this this
other person that wouldn't the so I
wouldn't have the burden of my own face
and I flew out to LA and we did a first
kind of whack at what this person might
look like and it was the moment when I I
looked up and it wasn't me anymore and I
and I realized
I realized that it was going to be
possible and I believed what that face
could do and it was totally through the
artistry of Matthew and I've worked with
Marcia now 4 for 20 years and I can't
tell you how excited I am that he is
sitting here today being recognized by
the nomination marcio mix mixes hair
color like other people like Matthew
mixes paint and it's astounding so and I
and I would not have done the movie
without either of you it would have been
impossible so can we open the the
curtain and let's take a look at the the
first picture that we have for Albert
Nobbs